scp-035 versus scp-049  an evil mask with frightening  supernatural powers against a plague  doctor tragically cursed with a deadly  touch but who would win in a battle  honestly this is a tough one whether  scp-049 couldn't kill one of 035's hosts  with a deadly touch is an open question  however it is possible if 035's host  isn't particularly strong that a legion  of the plague doctor zombies may be able  to bum rush it the real question and the  one we're having trouble with is whether  scp-035 could trap zero four nine and  convert him into another host it all  depends on the playability of the mask  because if the mask is rigid there's a  good chance that zero four nine's  unusual face shape would save his life  and bag him the victory over zero three  five